This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个来自 I-Heart 的播客。保证真人。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84 年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的年份了，尤其是对黑人而言。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
请在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要表现出来。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
请在 AHA Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023 年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 60s. psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course, break down the psychology of our 20s and back for a very
我发誓，我将是他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的报应。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends》。大家好，我是杰玛·斯派克（Gemma Spike），欢迎回到《心理学：你的 20 多岁》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们讨论 20 多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们 60 多岁意味着什么的播客。心理学。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们要剖析 20 多岁的心理学，并且回到一个非常
important episode at that. I want to do everything so I do nothing. This is our topic for today. I have so many dreams for myself and my life, but I don't chase any of them. I hear this all the time from people in their 20s. In fact, I think it is the biggest worry I hear from people during this decade. And it's also a major route of so much to satisfaction, not just now, but in the future. Obviously, it doesn't always sound like that, right? It doesn't always sound like somebody being like, I want to do everything, but I do nothing. It sounds like, I don't know which of these jobs to choose, so I'm just going to stay where I am. It sounds like, I don't know whether to stay or leave my relationship, so I guess I'll just stay. I don't know whether to honor my passions or my need for
重要的一集。我想做所有事情，所以我什么都没做。这就是我们今天的主题。我对自己的生活有很多梦想，但我一个都没有去追逐。我经常从 20 多岁的人那里听到这句话。事实上，我认为这是我在这个十年里听到的最大的担忧。这也是许多不满情绪的主要根源，不仅是现在，而且在未来。显然，听起来并不总是这样，对吧？听起来并不总是像有人说“我想做所有事情，但我什么都没做”。听起来像是“我不知道该选哪份工作，所以我还是留在原地吧”。听起来像是“我不知道该留下来还是离开我的关系，所以我想我还是留下来吧”。我不知道该尊重我的热情还是我对
stability, so I'll do neither. I don't know whether to travel or whether to save, so I won't do either as well. All of it is the same. It all comes back to this core dilemma. Our expectations for ourselves, our dreams, I guess, are so heavy that they often keep us pinned to one place. Safe, but not very happy. This conundrum is so interesting to me, because it's not that you can't achieve what you want if you set your mind to it. It's not that there is a lack of things that intrigue you or a lack of opportunities or ambition. In fact, I normally find that people who get stuck in this situation have an excess of ambition. Psychologically, it's about regret, right? And more than that, it is about fear. It is very easy
稳定性的需求，所以我两者都不做。我不知道该去旅行还是该存钱，所以我两者都不做。所有这些都是一样的。这一切都归结为这个核心困境。我们对自己的期望，或者说我们的梦想，太沉重了，以至于它们经常把我们钉在一个地方。安全，但并不快乐。这个难题对我来说非常有趣，因为并不是说如果你下定决心就无法实现你想要的。并不是说你缺乏让你感兴趣的事物，或者缺乏机会或野心。事实上，我通常发现陷入这种境地的人野心过剩。从心理学上讲，这是关于遗憾，对吧？而且更重要的是，这是关于恐惧。从外部看
from the outside to look at someone who is stagnant at this point in their life and assume that they are just lazy, they lack discipline, they lack motivation, they lack structure. I would say 80% of the time for people in this situation, that's not their problem. A lack of discipline is not the problem. It is this fear that's holding them back from just choosing somewhere to direct their discipline. So today we're going to talk about what's really going on and also my guide to taking all those options, taking all those dreams, and committing, choosing, chasing what you really want, even if you are entirely unsure how it's going to turn out. So without further ado,
一个在生活中停滞不前的人，很容易认为他们只是懒惰，缺乏纪律，缺乏动力，缺乏结构。我会说，80% 的情况下，对于处于这种情况的人来说，那不是他们的问题。缺乏纪律不是问题所在。正是这种恐惧阻碍了他们选择一个方向来引导他们的纪律。所以今天我们要谈谈到底发生了什么，以及我的指南，教你如何利用所有这些选择，利用所有这些梦想，去承诺、去选择、去追逐你真正想要的东西，即使你完全不确定结果会如何。所以，废话不多说，
let's get into the episode. Let's return to this main dilemma, wanting to do it all, not knowing which path is worth trying first, so doing nothing. This has been something that personally I've been dealing with a lot recently. Let's get Ken for a second. I'll be totally honest. I've been doing this podcast for five years now, literally for my entire 20s, minus like one or two years. I honestly want to do beyond this before I turn 30. And I just can't seem to take a step towards anything. I feel like I have a new, brilliant idea every week for how I want these last few years
让我们进入这一集。让我们回到这个主要困境：想做所有事情，却不知道哪条路值得先尝试，所以什么都不做。这确实是我最近一直在处理的事情。让我们坦诚一点。说实话，我已经做这个播客五年了，实际上是我整个 20 多岁的时光，减去一两年。我真的想在 30 岁之前做点什么。但我似乎无法迈出任何一步。我觉得我每周都有一个关于我希望 20 多岁最后几年如何度过的新颖、绝妙的想法。
of my 20s to go. You know, I really want to go back and get my PhD like I always wanted to. That was my path before this podcast happened. I really want to launch a business. I want to write another book. I think about a business idea like every day. Part of me also just wants to do nothing, but I have done none of these things. I think maybe because I'm leaving this invisible space for the most perfect, fully formed idea to like come along and like to have the space to complete it. I want to have this like full body confirmation reaction that I had when I started the podcast. That's like. I'm a lot of
你知道，我真的很想回去攻读博士学位，就像我一直想要的那样。那是这个播客出现之前的道路。我真的很想创业。我想再写一本书。我每天都在想一个商业点子。我的一部分也只想什么都不做，但我什么都没做。我想也许是因为我给那个最完美、最成熟的想法留出了一个隐形的空间，让它出现，并有空间去完成它。我想要那种我在开始播客时感受到的全身心的确认反应。那是……我很多
like the only time I've ever felt that. And because I feel like I felt that once, and because I took this one big risk, I'm like, oh, maybe I don't need to take risks anymore. Maybe I just need to coast. Maybe it really just comes down to this sense of like, I've just, I don't know, I feel like life has gone so well. I've got all this privilege. Taking the wrong step would be a disservice to everything that's gone well in my life. And I'm so young that like to set off in the wrong direction, feels like it would have such major consequences for me. So let's interrogate why that is, because you guys know I have a deep hunger for self-awareness. I'm not somebody who can leave my problems alone.
唯一一次有这种感觉。因为我觉得我曾经有过那种感觉，也因为我冒了这一个大险，我就想，哦，也许我不需要再冒险了。也许我只需要顺其自然。也许这真的归结为一种感觉，就像，我不知道，我觉得生活过得太好了。我拥有这么多特权。走错一步将是对我生活中一切顺利的事情的损害。而且我还很年轻，所以朝着错误的方向出发，感觉会对我产生如此重大的后果。所以让我们审视一下为什么会这样，因为你们知道我对自我意识有着强烈的渴望。我不是那种能对自己的问题置之不理的人。
This is what I've concluded from the research. This is why I feel like I'm staying still, as I'm sure many of you are as well. I know I mentioned fear. What I've realized is that it really comes down to three distinct fears. The fear of regret, the fear of failure, and the fear of being judged, the fear of being seen. Those kind of feel like similar fears, they are really, really different. Let's start with the biggest primary fear for so many of us, the fear of regret, the fear that we will choose one of these paths one day. We will choose that one, that path branching out in front of us, and we will find
这就是我从研究中得出的结论。这就是为什么我觉得我停滞不前，我相信你们中的许多人也是如此。我知道我提到了恐惧。我意识到它实际上归结为三种截然不同的恐惧。对遗憾的恐惧，对失败的恐惧，以及对被评判的恐惧，对被看见的恐惧。这些听起来像是相似的恐惧，但它们确实非常、非常不同。让我们从我们许多人最大的首要恐惧开始：对遗憾的恐惧，担心有一天我们会选择这些道路中的一条。我们会选择那条在我们面前分叉的道路，然后我们会发现
ourselves five, ten, fifteen years down the line in a place we don't want to be and unable to change it. We will find ourselves deeply resenting. the version of us right now who didn't know any better and chose the wrong path. The interesting thing about fearing regret or fearing the wrong outcome is that you're really just worried about a lack of control, right? It's actually quite a human fear. And you're really just worried about putting things in motion that will be unchangeable. And what it really comes down to is this deep knowledge that we as humans have less control than we think, but also our time here is finite, right? We can't do it all. So how do we know with certainty what choice is going to maximize
自己在五年、十年、十五年后处于一个我们不想待的地方，而且无法改变。我们会发现自己深深地怨恨现在的自己，那个当时不知道更好，选择了错误道路的自己。关于害怕遗憾或害怕错误结果的有趣之处在于，你实际上只是担心缺乏控制，对吧？这实际上是一种相当人性化的恐惧。你实际上只是担心启动一些无法改变的事情。而这真正归结为我们人类的一种深刻认知，即我们拥有的控制力比我们想象的要少，而且我们在地球上的时间是有限的，对吧？我们不可能做所有事情。那么我们如何确定哪种选择能最大化
our pleasure and our happiness whilst minimizing our pain? Which one of these is going to be the perfect combination of max pleasure, minimal pain? The thing is we don't. We only know in hindsight. Sometimes we don't even know in hindsight because there's no way of knowing if another path would have turned out any better. Really at this point, like you just have to bet on the one you think is best. What's ironic as well, and I think is a core part of this, is that the more choices we have, the more impactful and the more severe our paralysis analysis normally is. Which is funny, right? I think there's this logic that more choice and more ambition, more dreams, means it will be easier to choose because the right one is going to stand out.
我们的快乐和幸福，同时最小化我们的痛苦？哪一个会是最大快乐和最小痛苦的完美结合？问题是我们不知道。我们只有在事后才知道。有时我们甚至在事后也不知道，因为没有办法知道另一条路是否会更好。实际上，在这一点上，你只需要押注于你认为最好的一条。同样具有讽刺意味的是，我认为这是其中的核心部分，即我们拥有的选择越多，我们的分析瘫痪通常就越有影响力和越严重。这很有趣，对吧？我认为有一种逻辑是，更多的选择和更多的野心、更多的梦想，意味着选择会更容易，因为正确的那个会脱颖而出。
Unfortunately, that is not the case. There is a term for this. You've probably heard it. You've probably even heard it on this podcast. It is called The Paradox of Choice. The Paradox of Choice was, it kind of first appeared, actually, it didn't kind of, it first appeared as the title of a book by this American psychologist. His name is Barry Schwartz.
不幸的是，事实并非如此。有一个术语可以形容这个。你可能听说过。你甚至可能在这个播客上听到过。它被称为“选择悖论”（The Paradox of Choice）。“选择悖论”最初出现时，其实不是“有点”，它最初作为一位美国心理学家书的标题出现。他的名字叫巴里·施瓦茨（Barry Schwartz）。
and in this book, Barry talks about a very, very famous study, probably one of the most famous studies of all time. It was conducted in the year 2000. What it involved was a researcher, a researcher setting up a jam stand at a local supermarket. On day one, she has 24 jams. On day two, she only has six jams. The researcher was like, based on what I think I know about human psychology, when I have 24 jams, more people are going to buy a jam because their preferences are going to be reflected and represented by my options. The truth that really shocked researchers was
在这本书中，巴里谈到了一个非常、非常著名的研究，可能是史上最著名的研究之一。它是在 2000 年进行的。它涉及一位研究人员，她在当地一家超市设立了一个果酱摊。第一天，她有 24 种果酱。第二天，她只有 6 种果酱。研究人员当时想，根据我对人类心理学的了解，当我拥有 24 种果酱时，会有更多人购买果酱，因为他们的偏好会通过我的选择得到反映和代表。真正让研究人员感到震惊的事实是，
when there were 24 jams, only 3% of people were able to make a decision and purchase something. When there were six jams, 30% of people who came to the stand, bought a jam. Why? Because when we have too many choices, it actually doesn't equal freedom, it equals overwhelm. The pro-con list that our mind is mentally working through is too large.
当有 24 种果酱时，只有 3% 的人能够做出决定并购买东西。当有 6 种果酱时，来到摊位的人中有 30% 购买了果酱。为什么？因为当我们有太多的选择时，它实际上并不等于自由，它等于不知所措。我们大脑在心理上处理的利弊清单太大了。
It's too large to compare 50 options against each other versus two. And the risk of disappointment also increases with each new potential jam, because each new potential jam offers a whole new flavor that we could really, really love. We're not really talking about jam, right? we're not talking about jam, talking about our lives. And we're talking about the potential decisions or ideal selves or futures that we want to inhabit. It is paralyzing and it also makes us feel silly to be complaining about having so many options, so many goals that we can't choose one. But it stumps your brain. It creates the I do nothing part of this equation,
比较 50 个选项与两个选项相比太大了。失望的风险也随着每一个新的潜在果酱而增加，因为每一个新的潜在果酱都提供了一种我们可能真正、真正喜欢的全新口味。我们不是在谈论果酱，对吧？我们不是在谈论果酱，是在谈论我们的生活。我们是在谈论我们想要居住的潜在决定、理想自我或未来。这令人瘫痪，而且当我们抱怨有这么多选择、这么多目标却无法选择一个时，也会让我们觉得自己很傻。但这会阻碍你的大脑。它创造了这个等式中的“我什么都不做”的部分，
mainly because of cognitive overload and because of the possibility of making the wrong choice is so large and profound that it drives our behavior kind of counterintuitively to make no choice. So that's the fear of regret. Second is the fear of failure. This is different from our fear of regret because our fear of regret is about a fear of inaction.
主要是因为认知过载，而且因为做出错误选择的可能性如此巨大和深远，以至于它以一种反直觉的方式驱动我们的行为，导致我们不做任何选择。所以这就是对遗憾的恐惧。其次是对失败的恐惧。这与我们对遗憾的恐惧不同，因为我们对遗憾的恐惧是关于对不作为的恐惧。
So like leaving a stone unturned, leaving an opportunity not taken, our fear of failure is about the fear of action and the fear of making a tangible mistake rather than a mistake derived from not doing anything at all. It is the fear of committing and then being disappointed or being, you know, not being able to meet the expectations for this dream or this life that we want to create. You know what? That's a possibility.
所以就像未竟之事，未抓住的机会，我们对失败的恐惧是关于对行动的恐惧，以及对犯下实质性错误的恐惧，而不是源于什么都不做而犯下的错误。这是害怕承诺，然后感到失望，或者你知道，无法达到我们想要创造的这个梦想或生活的期望。你知道吗？那是一种可能性。
It's a real possibility. we might not have what it takes, and it really stings to think about it, because it gets all tied up in our self-worth, our self-esteem, our ego, like those little pesky things that we have to deal with. Nobody wants to feel like they weren't good enough or big enough for their dreams, or that they got so, so close and missed it because of something that they did. That is a big reality to consider. and you know what? Sometimes people do decide, I don't think I could survive that, so I don't want to take that risk. The fear of failure is too loud. But I truly believe that a lot of this really comes down to a lack of self-acceptance. And more specifically, a lack of self-trust, this belief that bad things could happen and you won't be able to survive them.
这是一种真正的可能性。我们可能没有能力做到，想到这一点真的很刺痛，因为它与我们的自我价值、自尊、自我意识纠缠在一起，就像那些我们必须处理的讨厌的小东西。没有人想觉得自己不够好，或者无法实现自己的梦想，或者因为自己做的事情而错失良机。这是一个需要考虑的重大现实。你知道吗？有时人们确实会决定，我不认为我能承受那个，所以我不想冒那个险。对失败的恐惧太强烈了。但我真心相信，这很多确实归结为缺乏自我接纳。更具体地说，缺乏自我信任，即相信坏事可能会发生，而你将无法生存。
If things do not grow perfectly well, you will not live. You will not be able to endure it. failure will become you. Failure will be a permanent state of mind that you will remain in. The thing is, it's not and it won't be. You can try again and again and again and again. In fact, most people do and will. You're going to be totally fine. In fact, a little bit of failure, I think especially in your 20s, is like healthy for you. It's part of a healthy emotional diet because it proves you are trying and you're putting yourself in the path of luck and opportunity. And it didn't hit you this time, but it could hit you next time. I also think that's why, again, inoculating yourself against failure as early as you can in life in your 20s, like basically allowing little failures to come in
如果事情发展得不完美，你将无法生存。你将无法忍受。失败将成为你。失败将成为你将保持的一种永久心态。问题是，它不是，也不会是。你可以一次又一次地尝试。事实上，大多数人都会这样做，也会这样做。你会完全没事的。事实上，我认为一点点失败，特别是在你 20 多岁的时候，对你来说是健康的。它是健康情感饮食的一部分，因为它证明你在尝试，并且你让自己处于运气和机会的道路上。这次没击中你，但下次可能会。我也认为这就是为什么，再次强调，尽早（在你 20 多岁时）让自己对失败产生免疫力，基本上允许小失败进入，
proves how capable you are of surviving what might be a bigger failure. And if you want a big life, like that may one day present itself. The possibility of big failures is going to be there. But it's no big deal. You've inoculcule. You've inoculing. yourself. You got the failure vaccine. It is nothing that you can't handle. There is this incredible piece of psychology research from 2003 titled Fear of Failure, Friend or Foe, which basically talks about how our fear of failure is not a singular thing. Your fear of failure can either lead you to work harder. This is what they call an over-striver response to failure, or it can lead you to develop defensive behaviors. This is called a self-protective fear of failure. So overstriver
证明了你有能力在可能更大的失败中生存下来。如果你想要一个宏大的人生，那可能有一天会展现出来。大失败的可能性会存在。但这没什么大不了的。你已经接种了。你已经接种了。你自己。你打了失败疫苗。没有什么你处理不了的。有一项来自 2003 年的令人难以置信的心理学研究，标题为《对失败的恐惧：朋友还是敌人》（Fear of Failure, Friend or Foe），它基本上谈到了我们对失败的恐惧不是单一的事情。你对失败的恐惧要么会导致你更加努力工作。这就是他们所说的对失败的“过度奋斗”反应，或者它会导致你发展出防御性行为。这被称为“自我保护式”的失败恐惧。所以过度奋斗
or self-protective. The thing is, you want to be an overstriver. If you cannot stop fearing failure, at least fear failure in a striving manner. Use it as a motivator, not as something that's going to handicap you from the start. Use it as something to look at and be like, I don't want that. And the biggest failure is not choosing, I'm going to work really hard. Our final fear, that we need to touch on today is the fear of not just failing, the fear of being seen to fail or the fear of judgment from others. Also part of this is with all these choices, sometimes the fear of confusing people with your direction. Sometimes like something not going right, choosing something else and thinking that people are going to judge you for that. When I talk to people who have this
或自我保护。问题是，你想成为一个过度奋斗者。如果你无法停止害怕失败，至少以一种奋斗的方式去害怕失败。把它当作一种动力，而不是从一开始就阻碍你的东西。把它当作一个可以审视的东西，并想：“我不想要那个。”而最大的失败是不做选择，我要非常努力地工作。我们今天需要触及的最后一个恐惧是，不仅是害怕失败，而是害怕被看到失败，或者害怕他人的评判。这也与所有这些选择有关，有时害怕因为你的方向而让人们感到困惑。有时就像事情进展不顺利，选择别的东西，并认为人们会因此评判你。当我与有这种
similar, I want to do everything, so I do nothing, fear, this actually comes up so often. It's this idea that we have promised people, we are this one type of person committed to doing this one type of thing. And so choosing something different or veering off course, maybe that makes us a liar. Maybe people would think weirdly, strangely about us. Maybe they would think that like, we're not disciplined or like we're entitled or like we just can't choose a lane. That potential for social judgment keeps us small in anticipation. To this I say, literally who cares? Be multi-hyphenate. Have the courage to just say,
相似的“我想做所有事情，所以我什么都不做”恐惧的人交谈时，这实际上经常出现。这是一种想法，即我们已经向人们承诺，我们是这种类型的人，致力于做这种类型的事情。所以选择不同的东西或偏离轨道，也许这让我们成了骗子。也许人们会奇怪地、异样地看待我们。也许他们会认为我们缺乏纪律，或者我们有权势，或者我们只是无法选择一条路。那种社会评判的潜力让我们在预期中变得渺小。对此我说，真的谁在乎呢？做个多重身份者。有勇气说，
that didn't work out. What's next? Have the courage to confuse people with how many interests you have. If they're thinking about you that much, you win. You are the one with the mental real estate in their mind. You're the one with the goals big enough that they are on their radar. That's crazy. That person's thinking about your goals, probably more than you're thinking about them. You're the one with the audacity to try rather than just to judge others for trying. That makes you a winner. Even if you publicly fail at something or whatever it is you're trying, you still win. Sometimes even having that rather slightly existential mindset of nobody's going to remember this anyway is really powerful. It's a very stoic mindset to have because you put distance between yourself, the potential outcome,
那没成功。接下来是什么？有勇气用你拥有的众多兴趣让人们感到困惑。如果他们那么关注你，你就赢了。你是那个在他们心中占据心理空间的人。你是那个拥有足够大的目标，以至于他们都在关注的人。这太疯狂了。那个人在想你的目标，可能比你在想他们还要多。你是那个有胆量去尝试而不是仅仅评判他人尝试的人。这让你成为赢家。即使你公开在某事上失败了，或者无论你在尝试什么，你仍然赢了。有时甚至拥有那种稍微存在主义的心态——反正没人会记得这个——也是非常有力量的。这是一种非常斯多葛派的心态，因为你在自己、潜在结果
and this person's potential opinion, and you see it really clearly in the grand scheme of things, their opinion will not matter on your deathbed. What will matter is realizing you didn't do the things your heart really called you to do because of their opinion. That will matter. You know what will also matter? Getting to tell yourself the story that you did it anyway. having a life of alignment, freedom, purpose that that person could never dream about because you just said,
和这个人的潜在观点之间拉开了距离，你非常清楚地看到，在宏大的计划中，他们的观点在你临终时不会重要。重要的是意识到你没有做你内心真正呼唤你去做的事情，因为他们的观点。那才重要。你知道还有什么重要吗？能够告诉自己你还是做了的故事。拥有一个与那个人永远无法梦想的对齐、自由、目标的生活，因为你只是说，
I do not care. Thank you for your opinion. Have a nice day. Sometimes, and this is another mental exercise I do, it's really helpful to see life as divided into teams, the people who had the audacity to try and the people who didn't. Which team do you think is having more fun? Which team do you think is happier? Which team do you think is having a better time on this earth? The audacity team.
我不在乎。谢谢你的观点。祝你有美好的一天。有时，这是我做的另一个心理练习，把生活看作分为两队真的很有帮助：有胆量尝试的人和没有胆量尝试的人。你认为哪一队玩得更开心？你认为哪一队更快乐？你认为哪一队在这个地球上过得更好？胆量队。
Dah. Be part of that team. Okay, we're going to take a short break here, but when we return, I want to give you a guide to picking. Let's pick together. What are you going to do first? What's the interest that you're going to commit to today? Stay with us.
哒。成为那一队的一员。好的，我们在这里休息一下，但当我们回来时，我想给你一个选择指南。让我们一起选择。你打算先做什么？你今天打算致力于什么兴趣？和我们在一起。
We're going to reveal all after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
在这个简短的休息后，我们将揭晓一切。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析关于心理韧性、健身和在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等交谈，以超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
我们在世界上感到惊慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, literally. But just so y'all know.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的对话，大谈 80 年代的快克（crack）。明确地说，84 年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我愿意在某天谈论快克，但是的，是的，确实。但只是让你们知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table. right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the
我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌面上还有艾滋病。谢谢你完成那句话。我不认为有比这更重要的年份了，尤其是对黑人而言。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是
most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade
美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了超过十年的
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
我在心理健康领域的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我在说。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine），瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different.
我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns），达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你发现做一个好人很重要，当你活在地球上时？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的
intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
意图，兄弟。绝对。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的只是做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的 IHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring, inconsistent. in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的、不一致的地方。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用于什么。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭开了一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县（Maricopa County）突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
规则一，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no, I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们决定采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓，我将是他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的报应。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。
Here is the truth that you've got to get really comfortable with. No, you cannot do it all. You just can't. That's one of the limits that we face as humans with finite time. But you can do a lot more than you think if you are able to surpass your decision paralysis. And here is exactly how I would go about it, how I'm going to try to go about it. And how I have in the past, I will say. Number one, stop trying to cram 60 to 70 years of goals and life into the next few months or the next few years.
这是你必须真正适应的真相。不，你不可能做所有事情。你就是做不到。这是我们作为时间有限的人类所面临的限制之一。但如果你能克服决策瘫痪，你可以做的事情比你想象的要多得多。这就是我将如何去做，我将如何尝试去做，以及我过去是如何做的。第一，停止试图把 60 到 70 年的目标和生活塞进接下来的几个月或几年里。
Stop compressing your timeline. And remember, like, goals take time, experience. come later on in life and in stranger ways than you would ever expect. And if you try to do everything at once, that is a very quick way to becoming disillusioned with your dreams, burnt out by your dreams, putting a lot of pressure on yourself, and also never getting anything done. Like, doing it all right now would be a disaster. This is what you have to do instead. I want you to treat your 20s. And with that in mind, like any decade of your life, really, like it is made up of five seasons, like a TV show.
停止压缩你的时间线。记住，目标需要时间，经验。在以后的生活中，以比你预想的更奇怪的方式出现。如果你试图一次做所有事情，那是对梦想感到幻灭、被梦想压垮、给自己施加很大压力，而且永远做不成任何事情的捷径。就像，现在做所有事情将是一场灾难。这是你必须做的替代方案。我希望你对待你的 20 多岁。考虑到这一点，就像你生命中的任何十年一样，它是由五季组成的，就像一部电视剧。
I spoke about this in my book, Person in Progress, by the way, if you want to buy it, but whether you divide your life or your decades up into seasons of two years, seasons of three years, maybe even five, you have to find a way to mentally represent your life so that it's not just like one clump of years extending out in front of you, one year after the next. Instead, there are segments. each new season is going to have different characters, different character arcs, different plot twists,
顺便说一句，我在我的书《Person in Progress》中谈到了这一点，如果你想买的话，但无论你是把你的生活还是你的十年分成两年的季节、三年的季节，甚至五年，你都必须找到一种方法来在心理上代表你的生活，这样它就不会只是像一团延伸在你面前的年份，一年接一年。相反，有片段。每一季都会有不同的角色、不同的角色弧线、不同的情节转折、
different destinations, different supporting characters, like there's going to be so much that's going to be different like different seasons in a TV show, different sets, different everything. And in each season, you have to choose your major focus and your minor focus. And until you realize you are bored of that focus or you finish that focus or you realize, you know, you realize it's not for you, you stick with. it. You give it everything. You don't get sidetracked. A major focus for the next three to five years could be finish my degree, launch my business, launch my podcast, write my book, travel, pursue acting, save for a property. And then your minor focus which can change like every year is something like
不同的目的地、不同的配角，就像会有很多不同的东西，就像电视剧里的不同季节，不同的布景，一切都不同。在每一季中，你必须选择你的主要重点和次要重点。直到你意识到你对那个重点感到厌倦，或者你完成了那个重点，或者你意识到，你知道，你意识到它不适合你，你就坚持下去。它。你全力以赴。你不会被分心。未来三到五年的主要重点可以是完成我的学位、启动我的业务、启动我的播客、写我的书、旅行、追求表演、为房产存钱。然后你的次要重点，可以每年改变，是像
get more hobbies, make a new friend, figure out my personal style, run a half marathon, something that's kind of more personal. Definitely something that's not as like career or finance focused. Two years, three years, five years, whatever segment works for you, during that time, you have to focus on your major goal. That is your only objective because it's not going to be forever. It's just going to be for this period. And after, let's say, three years, you have all the permission in the world to try something new or to pivot or to like quietly know, like, hey, I've accomplished that one. That's part of the, I want to do everything.
培养更多爱好、结交新朋友、找出我的个人风格、跑半程马拉松，一些更个人的事情。绝对是一些不像职业或财务那么专注的事情。两年、三年、五年，无论什么片段对你有效，在那段时间里，你必须专注于你的主要目标。那是你唯一的目标，因为它不会是永远的。它只是为了这段时期。在比如说三年之后，你有世界上所有的许可去尝试新的东西，或者去转型，或者像悄悄地知道，嘿，我已经完成了那一个。那是“我想做所有事情”的一部分。
I did that one thing. And that can remain stable whilst I go and do my other things. Like, I can say I did it. I can say I tried it. Now it's time to go do something else. You know, when I quit my job to do my podcast full time, I did say I'm going to give myself two years to just give it everything. Now it's like been three years later.
我做了那件事。当我去处理我的其他事情时，那可以保持稳定。就像，我可以说我做到了。我可以说我尝试过了。现在是时候去做别的事情了。你知道，当我辞掉工作全职做播客时，我确实说过我要给自己两年时间全力以赴。现在已经是三年后了。
It's been three years. And now I'm pivoting into doing other things. Like there are other things I want to do. I've given the podcast outside. of my job, such a big chunk of my time. Now I'm doing video podcast. Now I'm writing, like, writing another book. Like, now I'm doing these other things. Like, that gets my time now, and I don't feel guilty for not having given this previous thing my all. When you segment, when you say, this is my time for this and later, this will be my time for that, you give your
已经三年了。现在我正在转型做其他事情。就像还有其他我想做的事情。我把播客放在了我的工作之外，占用了我很大一部分时间。现在我正在做视频播客。现在我正在写作，就像，写另一本书。就像，现在我正在做这些其他事情。就像，那现在占用了我的时间，我不为没有把我的全部精力投入到之前的事情而感到内疚。当你分段时，当你说是时候做这个，以后是时候做那个时，你给了你的
individual dreams the space to breathe rather than like treating them like freaking cage chickens and cramming them all in with all the others. I feel like just to simplify this easily and just to make it like a quick mantra, date one dream at a time. A question that will probably come from this is like what dream do I prioritize first? I think this is actually rather, I don't know if this is privileged to say. I think it's a rather easy question to answer. You just have to use your regret thermometer here. Your regret thermometer is basically like asking yourself, what's the one I'm going to regret the most. What one hits the highest regret level in my mind? Like, what's the one that if I
个人梦想呼吸的空间，而不是像对待该死的笼养鸡一样把它们和其他所有东西挤在一起。我觉得为了简单地简化这一点，并把它变成一个快速的口头禅，一次约会一个梦想。可能由此产生的一个问题是，我应该优先考虑哪个梦想？我认为这实际上相当，我不知道这是否是特权说法。我认为这是一个相当容易回答的问题。你只需要在这里使用你的遗憾温度计。你的遗憾温度计基本上就像问自己，哪一个是我最遗憾的。哪一个在我心中达到了最高的遗憾水平？就像，哪一个如果我
am on my deathbed and I, if I die in like three months, I'm going to be like, why did I not do that specifically? That was a huge goal of mine. Why did I not do that? I also think a good exercise to do is just to sit down and really identify, like, if I'm going to choose the first thing I pursue, what are my values? What do I actually care about? What is the life you really want? Not the life you think you want, not the life others want for you. What is the life you want? Can you identify it? Is it wealth? Is it creativity? Is it connection? Is it comfort, excitement, adventure? If it's adventure, don't choose the strict corporate job first. Like that cannot be the first pathway. If your priority, your main value is adventure, that can come later. If a part of you really just knows,
在临终时，如果我在三个月内去世，我会想，为什么我没有专门做那个？那是我的一个巨大目标。为什么我没有做那个？我也认为一个好的练习是坐下来真正确定，如果我要选择我追求的第一件事，我的价值观是什么？我真正关心什么？你真正想要的生活是什么？不是你认为你想要的生活，不是别人想要你过的生活。你想要的生活是什么？你能确定吗？是财富吗？是创造力吗？是联系吗？是舒适、兴奋、冒险吗？如果是冒险，不要先选择严格的公司工作。那不可能是第一条路径。如果你的优先事项，你的主要价值观是冒险，那可以以后再来。如果你的内心深处真的知道，
I just want to live a creative, artistic, free life, don't choose the dream, the first dream, to be one that restricts you straight out the gate. Make that plan B. Take all the things that you really want to do. Write like a massive list. Actually like you can do this right now. Write a massive list. Anything that you're like not 100% like I would want to give my life to this.
我只是想过一种创造性的、艺术的、自由的生活，不要选择梦想，第一个梦想，成为一个从一开始就限制你的梦想。把那个作为 B 计划。把你真正想做的所有事情都写下来。写一个巨大的清单。实际上，你可以现在就做。写一个巨大的清单。任何你觉得不是 100% 像“我愿意为这个奉献我的生命”的事情。
Cross it off for now. Something you can do later. Like I think half the reason why we can't choose what we want to do, is because half of the things on our list are things that we don't actually care about. I think that like we sit down with all these thoughts like, but I want to be a doctor and I want to travel all the time and I want to run my rescue center and I want to be an artist or I want to be a mom or I want to be a dad and we're like, but wait, half those things are not things we actually want to do. Half those things are things that we think other people want from us. Like half those things
先划掉吧。以后再做也行。我觉得我们无法选择自己想做的事，有一半原因是因为清单上有一半的事情我们根本不在乎。我们坐下来思考时，会想：我想当医生，我想一直旅行，我想经营我的救援中心，我想成为艺术家，或者我想成为妈妈或爸爸。但等等，其实有一半的事情我们并不是真的想做。有一半的事情是我们觉得别人希望我们做的。就像那一半的事情
are things that we expect ourselves to want. So genuinely, go through that. list, cross out as many as possible until you get to the one that really stands out. That is where your regret thermometer is going to send you. Especially again, like if you are in your 20s, you have so much time. Those things, those plan Bs, like they can come later. You have heaps of time to settle. You have heaps of time for that. Just don't do it now. Like it's always going to be there. You can settle. That's why it's called settling. You can do whatever you want. You can't always do what you want to do right now whenever you want. Like, you may not have money or connections or stability, but you have gusto, you have enthusiasm, you have less obligation probably. That is an asset. Like, that is the asset of
是我们期望自己想要做的。所以，真心建议你仔细检查那份清单，尽可能多地划掉，直到剩下那件真正突出的事情。那就是你的“遗憾温度计”会指引你的方向。特别是如果你才20多岁，你还有大把的时间。那些事情，那些B计划，以后再做也来得及。你有足够的时间去安顿下来。你有足够的时间去处理那些。只是现在别做。反正它们一直都在那里。你可以安顿下来。这就是为什么它被称为“安顿”。你可以做任何你想做的事。你不可能随时随地都能做你想做的事。比如，你可能没有钱、人脉或稳定性，但你有干劲，有热情，而且可能负担更少。这是一种资产。这就是
your time. Please, please use it for something good and something fun or use it for literally anything. It doesn't matter what, as long as you care about it. The third thing I really want you to do is set decision timelines for yourself. Tell yourself and commit to starting when you say you will. Make a choice by a certain date. And then if you really want to go small, like, just do some micro-risks. Commit for like two months. Just go as small as possible. Just be like, I'm going to make a decision by here, by this time. This is the decision now for the next two months, two weeks, two years. Like, I'm just going to test it out, right? baby steps. Those baby steps are so crucial because they reduce the mental threat of an all-in,
你时间的资产。请务必把它用在有意义、有趣的事情上，或者随便用在什么事情上都行。只要你在乎，做什么都无所谓。我真正希望你做的第三件事是为自己设定决策时间表。告诉自己并承诺在你说好的时间开始。在某个日期前做出选择。如果你想从小事做起，那就做一些微小的尝试。承诺坚持两个月。尽可能从小处着手。就告诉自己：我会在这个时间点前做出决定。这就是未来两个月、两周或两年要做的决定。我只是想测试一下，对吧？小步快跑。这些小步非常关键，因为它们降低了那种“全押”、
like full stakes, no take-backs life change. And that's really important because probably something you're dealing with is just a lot of overwhelm and stress. So this just lets you concentrate on what's right in front of you, not the big outcome like two, three, 15 years down the line that is like its own scary monster level of fearful and terrifying. Pick something. you can do in the next two months for one of your dreams and action it. Finally, I want you to remember two final things. Firstly, you can jump across timelines. Making a choice in life isn't like strapping yourself to a train aboard unmovable tracks, like that you can never get off. It's like hiking through a forest where you can like push through the dense bush to change tracks when you
“孤注一掷、没有退路”的生活改变所带来的心理威胁。这非常重要，因为你可能正面临着巨大的压力和不知所措。所以，这让你能专注于眼前的事情，而不是两三年甚至十五年后那种巨大的结果，那简直是令人恐惧的怪物。选一件你能在未来两个月内为梦想做的事情并付诸行动。最后，我希望你记住两点。首先，你可以在不同的人生轨迹间跳跃。生活中的选择不像把自己绑在无法移动的火车轨道上，让你永远无法下车。它更像是在森林里徒步，当你
realize that you're lost. You can be flexible. If you don't like the life that you end up creating, You are not stuck there. You can borrow parts of other dreams that you have. You can go back to school. You can start over. You can practice as a novice. You can cut your own path through the forest. It's not this.
意识到自己迷路时，可以穿过茂密的灌木丛换条路走。你可以保持灵活。如果你最终创造的生活不是你喜欢的，你并没有被困在那里。你可以借鉴你其他梦想的部分。你可以重返校园。你可以重新开始。你可以以新手的身份去实践。你可以自己在森林里开辟出一条路。它不是这样的。
You are not tied to any particular life path just because it's the first train you got on. You can get off. There's heaps for you to get off. These are not locking contracts. You have agency. There are not clauses that are unchangeable. You can change at any time if you, if you want to, if you have like the spirit,
你并没有被束缚在任何特定的人生道路上，仅仅因为那是你上的第一辆火车。你可以下车。有很多机会让你下车。这些不是不可更改的合同。你有自主权。没有什么是不可改变的条款。如果你想，如果你有那种精神，你随时可以改变，
and if you have the resources that I'm sure you do if you're considering all these choices. And secondly, the final reminder, the one I wish I knew sooner, the very fact that you care now about making the right choice shows that you will always care. The very fact that you are worrying
如果你有资源——我相信如果你正在考虑所有这些选择，你肯定有资源。其次，最后一个提醒，也是我希望自己能早点知道的：你现在关心如何做出正确的选择，这一事实本身就表明你永远都会在乎。你担心的事实，
about not being able to do it all, worrying about your future self, worrying about regrets, shows that you have accountability over your life, life. And if you someday do encounter a life that you didn't sign up for, that emotional reaction, that same motivation is still there and it's going to propel you to change. I had this professor say to me once, the people who are anxious about making the right decision are never the ones I worry about. I worry about the ones who are apathetic. I worry about the ones who don't worry because that
担心自己无法面面俱到，担心未来的自己，担心会后悔，这表明你对自己的生活有责任感。如果有一天你真的遇到了一个并非你所愿的生活，那种情绪反应，那种同样的动力依然存在，它会推动你去改变。有位教授曾对我说：那些为做出正确决定而焦虑的人，从来不是我担心的人。我担心的是那些冷漠的人。我担心的是那些不担心的人，因为那
shows a lack of buy-in. That changed my life when he said that. Like the biggest mistake you can make will never be making a mistake. It will be not having the guts to fix the mistake or not caring enough to fix the mistake. You obviously care. That's why you're so worried right now. You obviously will always continue to have this force and this motivation in you that will want you to change your life. So choose whatever you choose and you will be fine. Like you will be okay because you are not apathetic. That's what all this worry proves. So that is all I have time for today. That is the end of my big rant about wanting to do it all and not doing any of it. I hope that this has helped you make a choice. I hope that it's at least helped you to be like, baby step. Like, audacity takes you
表明缺乏投入。当他说这句话时，它改变了我的人生。你可能犯的最大错误永远不会是“犯错”本身。而是没有勇气去纠正错误，或者不够在乎去纠正错误。你显然很在乎。这就是你现在如此担心的原因。你显然会一直拥有这种力量和动力，让你想要改变生活。所以，无论你选择什么，你都会没事的。你会好起来的，因为你并不冷漠。这就是所有这些担忧所证明的。这就是我今天所有的时间了。关于“想做所有事却什么都没做”的吐槽到此结束。希望这能帮你做出选择。希望它至少能让你觉得：迈出一小步吧。胆识能带你走
a long way. What am I going to be audacious about? What am I going to just concentrate on now just for the next little while, not forever. I hope that breaking it down has made that, like, the process behind why this is hard and how to overcome it, um, a lot easier. If you have made it this far and you were listening on Spotify, leave a comment down below. What is the dream? What is the ultimate dream that you have for your life? Why not? Put it out into the universe. What is like the thing that you really want to have happened for you? Put it in the comment section. Let's make, like, let's just put that one inch closer to reality. Let your say. self-verbalize it, maybe for the first time. Make sure that you're also following us on Instagram
很远。我要对什么有胆识呢？在接下来的这段时间里，我只专注于什么，而不是永远。希望拆解这些问题能让“为什么这很难”以及“如何克服它”的过程变得容易得多。如果你听到了这里，并且是在Spotify上收听的，请在下方留言。你的梦想是什么？你对生活终极的梦想是什么？为什么不呢？把它释放到宇宙中去。你真正希望发生的事情是什么？把它写在评论区。让我们把它向现实推进一英寸。让你自己说出来，也许是第一次。确保你也关注了我们的Instagram
at that psychology podcast. You can, of course, share your dreams with me over there as well. I'm always receptive to hearing them, especially if one of your dreams is starting a podcast. I'm always down to give some advice. Send this episode to somebody who you think it will resonate with. Follow us. You can also read the transcript of this episode on substaff. There are so many things that you could do with this episode. You could watch it on Netflix if you want it. I don't know if you that if you're new to this podcast, we are also on Netflix all over the world. So if you want to watch future episodes, past episodes, you're more of a visual learner. That is a great place for you to go and check us out. I think that's enough plugs for me. I think I've done enough. I think I've done enough
账号 @thatpsychologypodcast。当然，你也可以在那里与我分享你的梦想。我总是乐于倾听，特别是如果你的梦想是开播客的话。我总是很乐意提供一些建议。把这一集发给你认为会产生共鸣的人。关注我们。你也可以在Substack上阅读本集的文字稿。关于这一集，你可以做很多事情。如果你想的话，你甚至可以在Netflix上观看。如果你是这个播客的新听众，我不知道你是否知道，我们在全球的Netflix上都有播出。所以如果你想观看未来的剧集、过去的剧集，或者你更倾向于视觉学习，那是一个很好的去处。我想我的广告打得够多了。我想我已经做了足够多的
self-promotion for this episode. So yeah, do with that what you will. And as always, at the end of every episode, you guys know I say this, be safe, be kind, be very gentle to yourself, especially if you're like debating the future. It's a tough one to think about. But I'm 100% sure you're going to be okay. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs
自我宣传了。所以，随你怎么做吧。一如既往，在每一集的结尾，你们都知道我会说：注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，特别是如果你正在纠结未来的时候。这确实是一个很难思考的问题。但我百分之百确定你会没事的。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是走楼梯的人数比例，
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. And you will come out. on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
即使旁边有自动扶梯。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。我在我的播客《2%》中，剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何
survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the... 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起度过那段时光的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我不认为有哪一年对黑人来说比这一年更重要。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
你正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师和主持人Kear Games。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次伪造了这个特定的测试，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人经历了同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all day to do. the same prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都被同一个多产的骗子欺骗时，她们决定采取行动。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的报应。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证是人类制作。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。